- Is Canadian a language?
- I dated a girl from Montreal
for a year and a half.
I love Canada.
- All right! I've been there twice.
- [Voiceover] What is
the capital of Canada?
(laughing)
- I only know, like,
three cities in Canada,
so I'm just going to say them.
Montreal...
what's the other one?
- Canada's capital?
Ontario is a whole place...
- The capital, the capital of Canada?
- Let's go with Toronto,
where my Blue Jays at!
- It's either Toronto, Quebec,
or there's something with Victoria in it.
- Ottawa is a city?
- [Voiceover] Who is
the president of Canada?
(laughing)
- I don't think I've ever heard
of the president of Canada.
- Poutine.
- I bet he's bald.
Or like a stern lady.
- They don't have a president!
They got a prime minister, right?
- They got all that French influence.
Once you get Europe in your system,
all you're going to do
is have prime ministers.
- [Voiceover] Stephen Harper.
- Stephen Hopper?
- [Voiceover] Harper.
- Harper? Stephen Harper?
Stephen Harper.
- I was told that there wasn't
going to be math in this.
- A hundred million people.
- Under a million people.
- Thirty million?
- I feel like nobody lives there.
I feel like I've visited
and seen thirty people.
- They're a tenth the size of America?
- Canada's pretty big.
But just 'cause it's pretty
big, doesn't mean that
it has people everywhere.
'Cause it's kinda cold.
Drake doesn't even live
there, so that says a lot.
- Ryan Gosling.
That's the one I knew.
That's the one that I
should have remembered
because he's, like, perfect.
Bear.
- What lives in Canada?
A whale?
- Badger.
It's got to be a 'b'.
- A bear. No, a moose.
A bear moose.
- Ah, beaver.
Yeah, I knew it was a
'b' and it was mammal.
- It's a red maple leaf.
No, it's a white maple leaf on red,
or is it a red maple leaf on white?
Oh, I think I'm thinking of Japan.
I do care about Canada.
I'm from Wisconsin.
Although I'm very proud that
Wisconsin doesn't touch Canada.
People think Wisconsin does touch Canada,
but Minnesota's our little shield,
and Michigan's our little hat.
So they don't...
please don't put this in.